this is the moment the Venus volcano
erupts spewing plumes of smoke and rock
into the air the ubinas is Peru's most
active volcano it had been dormant since
2019. now Ash has blanketed communities
more than 20 kilometers away and
authorities are on alert
a supreme decree which effectively
declares a state of emergency in several
districts in the department of as it is
public knowledge the obinus volcano has
entered an eruptive process with
emissions that could affect the health
of the population
officials say more than 2 000 people
live in a radius of six kilometers
around the volcano most of them are poor
farmers and ranchers who've been asked
to stay home the governor of mokiewa
says the government must act immediately
to protect them
we don't want an emergency decree on
paper we want real and concrete actions
of the national authorities we want a
permanent presence in the area we want
the people to be heard
yeah
the volcano became active again last May
scientists say the ubinus is causing
more than 150 earthquakes a day but they
are still short of calling for an
immediate evacuation
we have to see an increase in the
seismic activity and register anomalies
in the temperature at the crater we're
evaluating the smoke must reach an
average two kilometers high and the
intervals of the earthquakes are closer
soldiers have been deployed to help the
population but local authorities say
shelters are unprepared they don't have
running water or sewage with warnings
volcanic activity is likely to increase
time to fully prepare may be running out
Mariana Sanchez Lima